[Music]
look you can show me an icy tundra if
you want but you've got to tell me what
year it is ah
1991 why did I have to wipe Bucky at
this point wasn't he wiped before he
went into the crown sleep also this book
that supposedly controls the Winter
Soldier is introduced here but wasn't
referenced in Winter Soldier at all and
Zemo found it buried in some assholes
wall in Cleveland so how did they
control him in the last movie 20 seconds
of interrupting Marvel logo why the hell
would you rob police stations another
maybe some extra weapons sitting around
in the evidence room but there's no way
there would be enough there to make it
worth it for super villainy also this
article is the newspaper version of
clickbait as the article underneath it
is some sort of vague repetitious
nonsense that's probably trying to sell
viagra the other barrier on the left was
still standing and the truck was
blocking the whole right lane but
seconds later these assholes somehow
drive straight through wide open
entrance make crossbones he'll be you're
expendable villain plot device for the
next seven minutes
I know cap is impervious to a lot of
stuff but this gas is apparently pretty
lethal if it didn't capacitated this
dude immediately in caps unaffected he's
also been developing an immunity to I
okay in powder that's badass but tell me
what kind of bullshit is this
how can a shield of this power bounce
off floors and walls instead of just
destroying them and how did cap the gear
out the geometry of that shop
I also agree this is cool but why didn't
he do something like this the very
beginning Scarlet Witch helpfully throws
the gas into the atmosphere where it can
affect many more people in Lagos Black
Widow canned through one of those taser
things faster than this asshole can fire
a bullet ah welcome back 500 edits per
fight editing how Scarlett's stunt
double doing great just great look I
have other people to talk to but we'll
have a beer later alright I know she's a
badass but come on Black Widow just took
out eight heavily armed bad guys did the
Avengers not have a drug testing
protocol in place
where these assholes doing this entire
fight our comrades are getting their
asses kicked but we see no reason to
step out of this tank and fire bullets
at anybody do to our conscientious
objections she survives this oh good
another villain who thinks he can win a
punching contest with Captain America
after cap inevitably wins I'm sure no
one else will try this during the rest
of this movie
his name is Red Wing he's cute better
huh huh huh while you guys are cracking
wise has anyone checked on cap Olsen ex
machina welcome to comic book movie
number two of the year where heroes get
all guilty about the innocent lives they
kill during their missions it only took
13 movies be nice tear he's been
studying abroad really which broad Roger
starkly less than zero CGI Robert Downey
jr. plus six hundred eleven million
dollars for my little therapeutic
experiment it appears that Tony is
merely being honored at MIT but he
decided to show the audience his virtual
reality memory which just so happens to
be important to the plot of this movie
also he could tell these students he
funded their dumb projects is this a
hologram teleprompter
do you mean all the students saw what
Tony was going to say albeit backwards
before he had a chance to say it I am so
sorry about the teleprompter I didn't
know miss Potts had canceled even if
they didn't know about pepper canceling
before the talk began it was the last
line of the speech so they totally had
time to remove the unnecessary reference
to a character we won't be seen be donut
I'm right where I want to be alfre
woodard somehow knew tony would be not
only exiting the stage this way but also
that he would bypass the bathroom and go
straight for the elevator míriam waste
State Department tax dollars by leaving
work driving to MIT and briefly with
Ironman victory at the expense of the
innocent is no victory at all damn it
sure got all Don of Justice he up in
here moving very specific unfortunately
her accent is not I'm lost and Bucky all
said now is a 16 year old kid again in
Brooklyn you could say that the word
Bucky is almost Captain America's
kryptonite or Martha
please we talked about this
beeping vision no vision Tom Captain
Rogers wished to know when mr. stock was
arrived so I came to Wanda's room right
away
world owes the Avengers unpayable debt
that's it he should stop right there
there is nothing else that needs to be
discussed not sokovia or Lagos or even
Manhattan they saved the universe
multiple times
how about dangerous as in Batman V
Superman the government comes in and
explains that they're scared of
superheroes now because of what they can
do and what's the difference between the
two movies again once brighter and tells
a few more jokes and doesn't suck I mean
what's the difference what would you
call a group of US based enhanced
individuals who routinely ignore
sovereign borders that seem unconcerned
about what they leave behind
um the Justice League Ryan Lochte also
the entire last part of the battle of
sokovia was the Avengers saving as many
individuals as possible discount
Quicksilver even died for a kid does
nobody want to mention this tell me
captain do you know where a Thor and
Banner are right now of course he
doesn't if he did this would be an
Avengers movie and it's totally not an
Avengers movie three days from now the
UN meets in Vienna to ratify the Accords
the sokovia accords were approved by a
hundred and seventeen countries and
somehow the avengers didn't get the news
until three days before the ratification
and if we come into a decision you don't
like then you retire apparently Ross
thinks he's Santos considering he makes
this statement as if he would have any
say in the matter also let's say the UN
decides they need the Avengers for
something how does that prevent the
Avengers from accidentally killing
people hey guys we need you but let's
try extra hard not to kill innocent
people this stunt
once again I'm happy they didn't have to
put the state or country that
Cleveland's in but do they have to use
the largest freaking font ever the cops
this guy who's definitely afraid of
anybody who might come by wanting to
steal the information he has willingly
opens his door to this guy without a gun
and a story that smells of immediate and
total bull I mean can you just say that
wasn't his car outside zimos power must
be x-ray vision considering he found the
book in an innocuous wall but the box of
water stops before his nose and mouth
and the water is already spilling out of
the box so zimos plan is to wash that
evil right out of his hair since mrs.
doc announced himself as AI man the
number of known enhanced persons has
grown exponentially during the same
period the number of potentially
world-ending events has risen at a
commensurate
but thinking about the conflicts that
arose in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
since Tony announced he was Iron Man
Thor came to earth because of some bulk
that happened on his own planet which
brought Loki and some dickhead robot
monster thing with it the Avengers movie
happened because of the stuff that
happened in Thor Iron Man 2 is because
some dude wanted revenge against Tony
Thor to the dark world
something-something realms something
something dark elves Iron Man 3 happens
because another asshole wanted revenge
on Tony
the Winter Soldier happens because Hydra
is still around and Avengers 2 happens
because Tony created Ultron and that's
the end of that argument ova site is not
an idea that can be dismissed out of
hand ok but you just mentioned that the
existence of the Avengers invites
conflict how would that change with any
administrative oversight Tony takes out
his phone and lays it in a fruit basket
so that it can play hologram footage of
somebody's dead son gee it sounds kind
of stupid when you say it out loud
aren't you the same woman who told the
government to kiss her ass a few years
ago I'm just reading the terrain first
off Falcon would be amazing at
cinemasins second off this bee or so off
character from Romanoff that I can't
stop saying on I just knew her as an
Peggy
it was a lot to live up to which is why
I never told anyone we were related
until now when the plot demands it and
I'm the featured speaker for her eulogy
I know what are you doing here I didn't
want you to be along also I needed to
give you in the audience some exposition
and set the stage for the next scene I
knew you'd be here well after the
funeral and didn't bother to call or
text first
wait they just found this bomb after the
van had been parked right across the
street from the meeting don't they check
that stuff before it gets to a horribly
strategic location he heroically jumps
into the blast but is one of the only
ones to survive this also who the
thought there would be a cataclysmic
event during a gathering of world
leaders well if you hadn't seen homeland
or does it need a survivor White House
down Independence Day Batman V Superman
or King Ralph this burgeoning
relationship when you boil it down it's
like Edward and Bella and Twilight Steve
something you got to see you need to
come take a look at this cock-blocking
cliche is 12 Undead 12 sure there's
probably gonna be more deaths later
because that's the way the news works
but that explosion blew up a whole city
block and I can't believe that when he
told everyone to get down that somehow
saved a lot of people mister its noise
thank God Sharon is Peggy's niece and
was here for the funeral and is in love
with Steve Rogers so she can pass him
important information illegally also why
do they think he could set off a bomb in
Vienna and make it back home in time to
arrest him that's a 12-hour Drive and
everything else requires a well-known
fugitive to go through airports or train
stations which I'm not buying
unless
the Buckey identity if Becky's face is
so well known that the news can casually
refer to him as the Winter Soldier
everyone knows what that means then how
can he walk around without getting a
disguise and without getting noticed if
he's been hiding out here for the last
couple here is more like Bucky rest am i
right does anyone want to shoot this guy
anywhere but is obviously bulletproof
and that's right it took four cups for
that one badass takedown
welcome to action movies in 2016 the
shooter from the UN task force just
fires with impunity without seeing
there's another person there it's almost
like they'll accept some collateral
damage for the good of the overall
mission luckily everyone can just
blindly jump down onto this busy road
without getting plowed into however
implausible this sequence is I'm gonna
remove a sin for black panther being a
badass or machine took so long to get
here they consider replacing him with
Terrence Howard we now take you division
and Scarlet Witch the most powerful
characters in this movie flirting over
some goddamn soup and what do you want
well people to see you aside so is this
getting serious if so what's that
bedroom gonna look like hang on Google
Maps tells me it's 18 King hours from
Bucharest of Berlin there isn't a task
force office in Bucharest or Belgrade or
anywhere nearby even Vienna's closer so
you like cats you're just now asking
this even if they flew here this banter
should have happened long ago your suit
vibranium the Black Panther has been the
protector of Wakanda for generations a
mantle passed from warrior to warrior if
you ask about the Panther suit you'll
get some heavy what cannon exposition
hello everyone I'm Everett Kay Ross from
the black panther series of comics I am
not to be confused with Thaddeus Ross
the guy from Incredible Hulk who also
makes an appearance in this movie I
would the task force released this
filler to begin much seems like a normal
thing that happens every time something
like this happens but Steve is
suspicious of it all so you had an
18-hour trip in a van to think about
this I can understand you being
suspicious but isn't that your nature
since Winter Soldier aren't you like
Sherlock Holmes now even though that's
Tony's job Jelani
hey dude there are ways not to listen to
this right like talking you've had a
couple years to create a defense against
this cap and Sam must have stopped off
for Starbucks enroute to the holding
room so that Bucky had enough time to
provide the mission report to Zemo and
kill all these government agents Jesus
this fight is like trying to watch
people play Marvel vs. Capcom and trying
to figure out what the fuck is happening
okay if we have to remove three sins for
this I guess we would sin counter will
not be happy
government agents and the rest of the
Avengers took their union mandated smoke
break during the whole escape chopper
crash scene cuz I'm not the only one or
soldier remember Bucky's only the Winter
Soldier because Zola remembered he got
thrown off the train in the first movie
and went backpacking in the mountains to
pick him up later for some dumbass
reason what's so special about Bucky
that they need to give him the serum in
the first place and they kidnapped a
whole bunch of people in 1991 and gave
them the serum and doesn't Hydra know
the ingredients of this cocktail they
had access to Zola for years I guess
they didn't because Bucky had to kill
Tony's parents forward and set up the
spite at the entities they can take a
whole country down in one night you
never see them coming
why haven't they that I know in Winter
Soldier Zola said something about blah
blah take away freedom blah blah people
resist but if you have 30 super soldiers
all created before the Avengers existed
then why not use them to do that very
thing who knows if the Accords a lot of
help but they're not ratified yet
remember bomb 72 hours guaranteed 36
hours arbitrary timeline is arbitrary
that's you right
I must know this because somewhere in
this YouTube video you take off your
mask 100 times following the existing
movies patterns and I've had these
powers for six months Peters only had
his Spidey powers for six months but
Tony's had time to scout him study the
strength of his webbing and build a suit
form you can't overpower me I know I did
she can why did she change her mind she
went from I've caused enough problems
and I think I'm in love with vision to
screw it in 30 seconds all because
Hawkeye told her to stop moping
wait did Wanda just send vision to hell
come on yeah when we're stopped -
Hawkeye a pic cap side just because
Quicksilver saved him in age of Ultron
you can't assume he'd go against the
other Avengers just to give Wanda a
right move well you will be moved as
entertaining as that would be it
wouldn't there'd be 1767 cuts just for
them to end up being friends anyway so
if you come with us you're a wanted man
yeah well what else is new so much for
spending time with her daughter which
was the whole reason you wanted to be a
good guy in your own movie
Cap'n Tony take an hour and a half to
start syllable war in your old war buddy
killed innocent people yesterday and
there are five more super soldiers just
like them but what's not important to
tell you at this moment is that Bucky
had no control over his actions because
there's a complicated series of
passwords that evil people programmed
him with and off oh come on
these webs are so strong that cap
himself can't get free of them but
Hawkeye's arrows are good enough ant-man
chooses to attack spider-man first
because arthropods I guess you have a
metal arm that is awesome dude thank God
they got a great actor got Spidey just
right even if he wasn't a Don you know
thank God Ironman decided to blast that
arrow out of the air there's no telling
what kind of property damage that would
have done don't worry no one will be
killed in the beautiful action
centerpiece of this movie so sit back
and enjoy the other lack of stakes
because we only know Steve and Tony
strong feelings on the sokovia accords
the other combatants in this melee start
to run together I've got to remember
Natasha's on Tony's side because reasons
Rhodey and vision are on Tony's side
because they're boring
Black Panthers simply only anti Winter
Soldier side Spidey's in it for the
money just like the studios involved
ant-man and Hawkeye are on Steve's side
because trying to figure that out
vonda's on Steve's side because of peer
pressure but I generally forget every
bit of that after every 10 seconds of
random hero and hero violence I didn't
kill your father
why did you run what kind of question is
that he was running because you were
chasing him in a scary cat suit doesn't
it feel like Scarlet Witch could just
end this whole battle right now you know
because she's the one who practices real
magic
you got a hard kid are you from please
Brooklyn does Brooklyn have that kind of
hard reputation anymore I mean isn't
book won one of the most gentrifying us
places in the world right now
I mean maybe because cap comes from
old-school Brooklyn he still wears that
like a badge but I for one can't wait to
decorate my bed-stuy brownstone with
French coffee shop posters and my three
bicycles I'll take the vision you get to
the jack by the way Tony side could stop
this whole thing by simply destroying
the jet for disabling it nobody
gonna do that alright Sam what's the
plan we need a diversion
The Avengers always have these
communication devices built into their
uniforms but if half of them are using
them shouldn't the other half be able to
hear the same conversation did they meet
earlier and determine which side uses
which frequency it's just the title of
the movie is all Paul Rudd is such a
goddamn national treasure and a welcome
bit of levity in this movie that I'm
removing a sin for his awesomeness
vision finally decides to start
visioning also seriously did this movie
just have no clue how to use this
character all he's done is a spouse
random wisdom cook and wear some j.crew
not gonna stop what the hell is she been
doing this whole time she got knocked
out of the battle earlier so then she
decided to hang out by the jet she was
gonna be the last defense against
captain freakin America heartbeat
detected why don't we just call this
movie civil unrest or domestic
disturbance to the one without Vince
Vaughn what's so wor about this civil
anyway sorry just like my mom said it's
all fun and games until someone gets
knocked out of the sky by an infinity
stone and breaks their back where police
also found a wig and facial prosthesis
approximating the appearance of one
James Buchanan Barnes Zemo seriously
found ways to do amazing things over one
year's time he's not only great with
computers and decrypting classified
documents but also making a mask of
Barnes that fools facial recognition
software get this - Ross which one also
if he's sending it to Ross why can't
Tony also send the information - black
panther whom he knows is still hunting
Bucky does this facility still have
power
start facial scanning for this Simo guy
you seriously think I'm gonna listen to
you after that Fiasco in Leipzig look
you're not in one of these cells
high-ranking government official thinks
he's in a Transformers movie in ignores
obvious evidence of an international
catastrophe did he give you anything on
Rogers not told me to go to hell Ross
who doesn't trust stark when it comes to
Zima suddenly trust stark in the
situation and doesn't haven't followed
oh how lucky Black Panther just happens
to be five seconds behind Ironman even
though he was secretly following cap and
Bucky the whole time what was your name
again
Dolores you called her da Steve
remembers the name of some random
redhead Bucky tried to impress more than
seventy years ago okay a cabin Bucky no
the exact coordinates and they have a
serious head start Tony had to take
Rhodey to the hospital chat with scar
Joe right out to the wavy prison talk to
Papa Doc to get the location then fly
all the way to goddamn Siberia but they
arrived if roughly the same time I know
that run you know that road what about
that date maybe that's more recognizable
yeah just incredible footage on a tree
line country road km3 as it turns out
cams everywhere in the area you never
know when Bigfoot might be around and
the footage was saved even though we're
seeing this in full color the movies
trying to say Tony can see this same
angle in footage - driving home the
drama of his mother getting strangled
but really all he'd be able to see is
Bucky standing next to the car doing
something probably bad presumably this
means he shot the camera but it was
conveniently impervious considering we
have this footage also suddenly this
movie is saying there was a facility
nearby that could capture security
footage first off that's terribly
convenient but second off terrible
nonsense because there was no such place
nearby in the beginning of the movie now
Tony gets mad even though he knows for a
fact that Bucky had no control over his
actions or is this movie saying he
didn't I find that hard to believe
and even though he just learned somebody
framed Bucky ten minutes ago he gets
blinded with anger this conflict as his
manufactured as it gets
did you know yes to be fair the only
reason he knows is because Zola showed
him what Hydra did the people who work
for shield in that bunker scene in the
Winter Soldier but then right after that
Hydra fired missiles into the building
and he had to make a miraculous escape
so it might have slipped his mind I
still can't believe this is the reason
they're gonna fight them all so when
would he tell Tony about this while they
were just hanging out hey man I know
where the strip club and stuff but Bucky
killed your parents she's older you
wanted to see them rip each other hot
pot yep and just think he could have
done this by simply sending the tape to
Tony with a little post-it note that
read play me we're miles from harm and
the dust cleared it took me two days
until I found that body but if they were
together how did demos survive if I
could get them to kill each other let's
talk about zimos plan the entire thing
relies on Scarlet Witch doing something
incredibly stupid during the crossbones
fight in Lagos without that there would
be no sokovia in the course which Zemo
had no idea what happened when he
started planning his revenge and yet is
a huge part of the plan in this movie
then he plots to bomb the
when frame Bucky and somehow someway he
knows Steve and Tony will hate each
other over it and he also knows Tony
will figure out about the dead
psychiatrist at the perfect time learn
the Siberia location and show up at the
same time as captain bucket he knows
Steve won't tell Tony what he knows that
it lose all control and they'll fight
each other in this building I mean how
does mo know all this just by pouring
over a Natasha's Wikileaks analyze his
fight pattern scanning oh sure you can
analyze his fight pattern but your
targeting system a minute ago was
totally messed up your does whatever
this movie needs doesn't it again he's
not gonna die what a pussy this movie is
Valentine all that effort will see it
fail so spectacularly did it well pretty
much yeah I mean Bucky lost an arm but
generally cap and Tony are good to go
for infinity war unless they're saying
there's more to zimos plan like he's
Joker in the Dark Knight and he needed
to be captured more proof that the
filmmakers lost sight of their vision
Stan Lee finally makes an appearance in
one of these Marvel movies geez only
took 13 tries but they found a way to
pay tribute to him yeah I guess I
thought by not telling you about your
parents I was sparing you but I can see
now that I was really sparing myself
from what also the I didn't tell you so
that I could protect you cliche once
again aren't you glad that you waited 10
minutes to see this thing and you have
no clue what it is
guess I'm gonna have to go research this
now thanks Obama
what's so civil about warmer
[Music]
our very strength invites challenge fear
leads to anger anger leads to hate hate
for more than a year Donald Trump has
been the people's champion they can take
a whole country down in one night you
never see them coming I'm a surprise
Kevin they don't see me coming I didn't
kill your father
my name is Inigo Montoya you killed my
father
prepare to die analyze this fight
pattern first distract target then block
is blind jab count with cross two left
cheek discombobulated date will attempt
wild haymaker employ elbow block Tony I
could use a good man to help me get my
project on wheels I'll keep an eye out
for you and the chessboard ready so no
matter what I promise you if you need us
should you need us yes
should you need us for any reason at all
I'll be there